[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN: Hey, Craig.
CRAIG: Hey, Martin.
What are you working on?
MARTIN: I built a web app
and a mobile app that display
info about famous artists.
It is backed by a REST
API running on Cloud Run.
But users are reporting
that it's sometimes slow.
Can you help me speed it up?
CRAIG: Yeah, absolutely.
It sounds like you might
need a caching layer.
Let me show you how it's done.
MARTIN: Great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN: All right,
Craig, so here is my API.
If I hit the URL here, it
takes three seconds to respond.
CRAIG: Three seconds?
What does your code look like?
MARTIN: [LAUGHS]
Yeah, here it is.
This call here runs a
complex database query.
It takes several
seconds to complete.
CRAIG: I see.
So you could try to save
recently accessed artists
in a cache, and that would
make your slow database query
run less often.
And it looks like your
data structure here
is pretty simple.
It's just an ID that
points to an object.
And that really lends
itself to a key value cache.
MARTIN: Sounds good.
Can you show me how to do it?
CRAIG: Absolutely.
Click Memorystore in
the Cloud console.
Memorystore is built to handle
exactly this kind of caching.
MARTIN: I will
pick Redis for now.
And I'm enabling
Memorystore in this project.
CRAIG: Great.
Now, click Create Instance,
and give it an instance name
and display name.
And then for the rest of the
fields, the defaults are fine,
so you should be able to
click the Create button.
Now your Redis server
is being initialized.
And this server sits in
a virtual private cloud.
So it's not accessible
from the outside internet.
That means the next
thing we need to do
is set up a connector
so that your Cloud Run
service can connect to
this virtual private cloud.
And to do that, first
pick VPC network
in the navigation sidebar.
Then click Serverless
VPC Access.
Now, click Create Connector.
Give it the name
my-vpc-connector.
Under Network, pick default.
And under subnet, Pick Custom IP
range.
Now in the text box, enter the
suggested value of 10.8.0.0.
That works great.
And click the Create button.
Now, let's head back
over to Memorystore,
and copy the IP address
of the Redis instance
that we just created.
Now, in your deployment script,
add $REDIS_HOST, $REDIS_PORT,
and vpc-connector as
environment variables.
MARTIN: Now that is done.
I will enter the code
snippet you sent me.
CRAIG: Awesome.
That subnet creates
a Redis client
object so that
your other code can
use that to access the cache.
And then instead of calling
getArtistsFromDatabase,
we can call a new function,
getArtistFromCache.
Now, in this new
getArtistFromCache method,
the first three
lines simply make
the Redis client use promises
instead of callbacks.
And this just makes your
code easier to read.
Then the code checks to see if
the artist with the given ID
is in the cache.
If it isn't, it calls
getArtistsFromDatabase and puts
that artist in the cache.
Finally, it reads the
artist's record from the cache
and returns it.
MARTIN: I'm deploying the
updated code to Cloud Run.
Very good.
The code is now deployed.
I'm hitting the URL now.
Oh, it's still as
slow as before, Craig.
CRAIG: Yes, of course,
because the artist is not yet
in the cache on
that first request.
But if you reload the page, I
think it'll be a lot faster.
MARTIN: I'm reloading.
Oh, that was a lot faster.
Cool.
But what if I need
to update that artist
record in the database?
CRAIG: Well, then you'll need
to update it in the cache, too.
I sent you some
more code for that.
Did you get it?
MARTIN: Ah, yes.
Let's see.
Entering it now.
CRAIG: Great.
So this method uses
the request payload
to update both the cache value
and any database records.
So the cache is never stale.
MARTIN: Excellent.
Let's redeploy the API.
Now back to Postman.
Here, I have a put request that
will add the field movement
to Frida Kahlo's artist record.
She belonged to the
surrealism movement.
CRAIG: Well, that's
perfect, because you're
going to have a surreally fast
API with all this caching.
MARTIN: [LAUGHS] Maybe don't
quit your day job, Craig.
Now, to reread
that artist's data.
Ah, and here it is with a
new movement field added.
And it was very quick
served from the cache.
Thanks for helping me
speed up my API, Craig.
CRAIG: Happy to help.
Now, right now,
your code is using
the read-through and
write-through caching
strategies.
And they work pretty well
for most applications.
But you might also
want to search
online for some other
caching patterns in case
those work better for your app.
Now, also remember that
your code can never
count on this object
being in the cache.
That's why we still have
the database backing it up.
When a cache fills up, it can
kick out objects at any time.
MARTIN: Oh, right.
Thank you for that
reminder, Craig.
And thank you,
everyone, for watching.
You will find a
link to the code and
to the Memorystore documentation
in the description below.
Please let us know
in the comments
if you found this episode useful
or if you have suggestions
for future episodes.
CRAIG: Happy caching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]